we are a rumor recognizable only as deja
vu and dismissed just as quickly
we are the best-kept secret in the
universe I know I want in you erase my
parents memories that you didn't get
mine took me 20 years to find you how
many people can say that I found you
which makes me perfect for this job
[Music]
how did you reefer
you will be with Asian Paints MIB you
Karelian scum an FYI your little Club
here sucks
come on well it's not gonna save itself
I'm driving that really should be here
Joey I thought that we were here we are
[Music]
wait are you a queen indeed she is
I pledge loyalty a turtle to you no no
no I'm not interested too late I already
pledged the loyalty I wish you'd said no
no no before we've never faced a threat
like the hive they can take the form but
anyone I haven't seen that before
our own agents do we have a plan
sometimes you have to trust your gut
men and black has been compromised on
trusts no one we protect the earth
that means everyone and everything on
yeah we love a man in black the men and
women in black yeah perfectly good are
you suggesting that we try the most
powerful weapon in the galaxy for fun do
it press the button turn it up as you
you
you